good morning Hank it's Tuesday morning
job that's really not my best work we
very nearly had actual brothers on a
hotel bed Hank it's question Tuesday the
day that we answer real questions from
real nerdfighters and you are going to
have to figure out the theme of my
question I didn't look okay what in your
opinion is the most beautiful word
I like penumbra for me it's ongoingness
I don't like twelfth that's a hard one
twelve what was the most foolish thing
you did as a child I remember getting in
a lot of trouble for throwing glass
bottles off of our fort Hank what do you
think it's the most beautiful phenomenon
in the Anthropocene I bet there's a
couple colors that didn't exist until we
came around that are pretty good I was
gonna say the understanding of the speed
of light that's good too
Hank what is your all-time favorite
foolish endeavor I have an answer for
this my all-time favorite foolish
endeavor is a guy named Tony Hawk's
hitchhiked around the circumference of
Ireland with a refrigerator to win a bet
and the book that resulted is as amazing
as you would hope that's a good foolish
endeavor you know I was just gonna say
all of humanity have you gotten the
theme of the video yet
no I didn't yeah I didn't get this are
you serious
and now you seriously don't have the
theme of the video no well I wasn't
paying a ton of attention what was it
favourite word and then there was like
stupidest thing you done mm-hmm I think
everybody out there has been doing this
might get you to the theme okay what is
foolish okay it's okay finally what is
foolish but also beautiful
the Internet and also humanity what and
porcupines we're liking a lockstep and
Internet humanity
porcupines I didn't have that one I was
gonna I was gonna go like jalapeno
poppers what is the best advice you ever
got from your kid sometimes Oren will
say feel happy that's good
one time one of my kids said it's just
YouTube are there any old school
nerdfighter isms that have made their
way into your everyday language in the
very first vlog brothers video ever the
camera turns off and you say auto power
off still some glitches to work out and
I say auto power off still some glitches
to work out all the time every time
something goes wrong with the camera 13
years later I'll still be like auto
power off still some glitches to work
out is humanity worth saving oh yeah yes
I thought about this a bunch actually
right it's sort of what you write about
in your novels yeah I think super yes
yeah in fact I will get into that cut of
that conversation fairly deeply in this
book great I can't wait I'm almost done
I will send it to you probably Monday
have you stayed in any hotel rooms as
good as the one that had that Picasso
since 2012
I've never nope not even close we almost
always stay in courtyard by Marriot
thank you there's actually a courtyard
in this one which is unusual Hank do you
think that I should go back to sports
Twitter my Twitter account at sports
with John not regular Twitter I think
you should do what you want to do John
since I left
Twitter Liverpool Football Club have not
lost a game in the Premier League so why
would I go back I'm the one who's making
it happen what's the last movie that
made you cry it was as the last movie I
saw which was a little lemon which was
very good every movie makes me cry like
I haven't I haven't seen cats yet but
I'm sure it will make me cry I want to
see cats
I don't mmm but I support people who do
I'm not here too harsh on your yums if
you like cats whatever that's great God
thank God that somebody likes something
somewhere Hank
mmm-hmm I will see you I will continue
you know yeah all right